[Music]
one of the newest
ways of thinking about problem solving
for me
is um something that my math professor
would tell me um he would say
don't be afraid to be stuck
and
i think that a lot of the time when we
are doing math and we get stuck it's
like
sometimes it can be you can feel like
wow this is a reflection of me and my
mathematical abilities wow maybe i
shouldn't be doing math
but really a lot of the time it's just
an indication that you need to spend
more time uh doing the math or figuring
out what the problem is exactly if you
haven't gotten stuck yet then i mean you
probably will get stuck at some point so
being stuck is just a part of math and
it's kind of learning how to what to do
when you are stuck is a really big uh
a big part of being creative in math and
being able to um solve homes in the
future one example um that i often use
um is
i often try to solve problems
both in like the traditional um
algebraic way but i also
try to visualize problems
in 2d and 3d space
to solve them more visually and so i
think
the more ways that you can figure out
how to solve a problem um the more ways
that you can eventually sort of like
save in your toolbox and use
later on to solve
other problems there's lots of different
tools and resources apps and puzzle
games that are going to help you think
about problems in new ways and help
develop that critical thinking that you
need to be able to apply your skills to
a lot of different areas
and sometimes even starting at the
answer and working backwards through the
problem can help you see a different way
of getting to the answer
students can combine new ways of
thinking about problem solving by trying
to look at it from different angles
anytime you approach a problem if you're
just looking at it from your perspective
you're not going to get a holistic view
of the solution space so try to have
perspectives and look at the problem
from multiple angles to understand
all the ways in which it could be viewed
the more holistically you view a problem
the more paths you look at the more
efficient and effective you're going to
be at solving it
[Music]